pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pensais alain giletti n'a pas une
chance aux jeux olympiques jusqu'à la
fin de l'épreuve de patinage artistique
il a cru qu'il obtiendrait la médaille
de bronze c'est à dire la troisième
place du classement à l'issue des
figures imposées il était encore
troisième dans les figures libres qu'il
n'a pas convaincu le jury
s'il termine l'épreuve à la quatrième
place et voici la grande étoile de la
spécialité l'américain alan jon kyl son
numéro est extraordinaire jugez en vous
même
[Musique]
médaille d'or pour jenkins qui est
vraiment le meilleur
la descente la plus belle épreuve les
disciplines alpines voit le trion de les
skieurs français
en attendant voici quelques hordes
passons maintenant aux choses sérieuses
jean verney prend le départ
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
jusqu'à l'arrivée il réalise une course
merveilleuse qui lui vaut le titre de
champion olympique amy la lettre le
félicite
après l'arrivée
remise des médailles jean vuarnet
médaille d'or à ses côtés hamster la
niche médaille d'argent et guy périllat
médaille de bronze
[Musique]
quatre jours quatre départements 17
villes le président de gaulle au cours
de son voyage dans le midi après seize
fois la part à albi puis à castres il a
réaffirmé sa politique
d'autodétermination pour l'algérie près
de narbonne où il a visité une usine de
raffinage d'uranium
cette matière première de l'énergie
atomique il confirmait ses paroles nos
moyens de défense nous permettront
d'apporter notre contribution à la
liberté du monde
et partout à l'image d'alès qui
n'avaient pas reçu du chef de l'état
depuis lui 13
la venue du président de la république a
suscité la même chaleur
à béziers par exemple et plus tard à
montpellier où le général de gaulle
devait aborder les problèmes ruraux en
affirmant il y a dans l'agriculture un
capital moral et social dont la france
ne peut se passer
[Applaudissements]
une grande dame du royaume d'angleterre
s'est éteinte à portsmouth la royal navy
lui a rendu un hommage selon ses voeux
la dépouille de l'est dimanche battle
épouse de l' amiral de la flotte et
tante du prince philippe de démo ne
reposera pas en terre
une frégate la conduite en pleine mer
pour lui donner la sépulture des marins
ainsi s'achève conforme à une vie passée
à sillonner le monde
une destinée hors série quelques fleurs
sur la mer bientôt dispersé marqueront
seul le deuil qui vient de frapper la
famille royale au moment où elles
avaient toutes les raisons de se réjouir
[Musique]
en effet après la naissance d'un prince
les sujets de sa majesté ont appris
qu'un photographe
le photographe officiel de la cour il
est vrai avait rendu son sourire à la
princesse triste
anthony armstrong jones épousera magath
[Musique]
la bague de fiançailles est passé que
d'émotions pour les coeurs sensibles
[Musique]
pour ceux qui pensent que le cinéma et
l'art du trucage voici des images bien
réels dont l'authenticité a coûté à un
producteur italien pour quelques
secondes de projection 6 millions de
lits
attention regardez bien
[Musique]
à paris le grand palais a connu son
dernier salon où l'on cause cuisine
l'année prochaine en effet le salon des
arts ménagers émigrera au rond-point de
la défense avec son univers magique où
tout semble se faire tout seul et ses
innombrables machine qu'il a avec qui et
sort qu'ils font à volonté le chaud et
le froid
[Musique]
cette année 1500 exposants ont rempli le
grand palais on rencontre la défense
ils seront plus nombreux encore plus
qu'ils accueilleront des exposants
étrangers
aussi n'est-il pas inutile de pouvoir au
passage faire le point dans une
encyclopédie l'univers ménages est
aujourd'hui si fourni et nos grands
mères auraient été bien étonné
d'apprendre que leur bon vieux torchon
de cuisine se transformerait un jour en
rouleaux de papier
[Musique]
et si vous éprouvez une tentation
d'élégance vous pouvez vous composez un
collier avec ses berlingots de 6
[Musique]
le carnaval à ces sites est privilégié
où les foules se retrouve en italie
c'est via make
ces chars aux machineries d'une
complexité inouïe ont acquis depuis
longtemps la célébrité
[Musique]
au portugal les story
le carnaval est né l'année dernière pour
sa deuxième manifestation il a créé un
cortège où don quichotte escorté par
l'adp carton-pâte qu'avec quelques
ressemblances avec fernandel qu'odile
versoix et collègue du val ont sans
doute préféré le vrai car il était là
roi de la fête
[Musique]
pendant ce temps nice en était à son 76e
carnaval
[Musique]
nice s'est acquis une spécialité celle
des grosses têtes
[Musique]
et la foule a des traditions solides
tels la bataille de confettis de la
place masséna
[Musique]
féminité souplesse gaieté des couleurs
qu'elles sont chez christian dior les
tendances de la mode de printemps les
épaules sont dégagées la veste et la
jupe confortable est à 42 cm du sol
[Musique]
voici deux mains un ensemble tailleur et
manteaux en lainage vertige graphic
robes blouses en lainage animé par une
coupe vivent des vagues peu l'après midi
haymoz une robe habillée en twill
imprimé bleu vert et mauve gong robes
blouses en shantung imprimés brun et
corail pour aller aux courses grand prix
robes et manteaux à l'imprimé à fleurs
fuxia et pour les petites soirées nuit
de singapour en faille turquoise brodé
leblanc et surprise sous la jupe un
ensemble de torre vous pour le soir si
rennes on allait aussi un verre d'eau la
simplicité de la robe 9 bali robe du
soir en tulle brodé de corail d'or
courte devant une traîne car et permet
les plus gracieuses effet iran en tulle
brodé turquoise sinueuse galbées la
silhouette 1960 créée par yves
saint-laurent évoque la rigueur des
sculptures de l'ancienne egypte c'est au
nom de la ligue nationale française
contre le cancer je m'adresse à vous il
s'agit de lutter contre un fléau qui tue
en france 90 mille personnes chaque
année
mais il paraît que l'horizon s'éclaircit
déjà une personne sur trois peut guérir
si le diagnostic est précoce et si elle
est traitée dans un centre bien équipé
de nombreux savants travail à vaincre ce
mal et ils réussiront mais pour tout
cela il faut de grands moyens lorsqu'il
s'agit de sauver une vie humaine
peut-être celle d'un être cher peut être
la sienne propre
qui songerait refusé son aide pendant la
semaine du 7 au 13 mars
des capteurs partout en france la
solliciteront nous serons tous très
généreux car lorsque le cancer sera
vaincu
la vie nous paraîtra plus belle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]